[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'atelier mac est donc
comme à berne où la cabine de peinture
la zone de préparation peinture et
résines
c'est dans cet atelier que s'opère la
restauration des monuments de france
miniature
la plupart sont démontables et amener
directement sur place pour la
restauration objectif rénover les
maquettes produite il y a trente ans et
corriger certaines faiblesses une
activité au croisement de nombreux
métiers artistes soudeur ou encore
menuisier là bas on a différents
lapidaire qui sont en fait des systèmes
de ponçage abonde qui permettent de
générer des volumes juste à partir de
ponçage on va avoir une scie à ruban une
perceuse à colonne et puis quelques
machines un petit peu plus mécanique un
tour et une fraiseuse pour faire
certaines pièces de révolution satin
dessin particulier sur les pièces
l'atelier détient également tous les
stocks de wagons et de matériel roulant
du parc situé à elancourt une partie
essentielle du site 16 circuits sont
répartis dans le paysage trois
kilomètres et demi de voies ferrées des
trains qui parcourt 50km au quotidien et
travaille dix heures par jour
le matériel a été développé pour le parc
on a ici
ben justement le dernier train sur
lequel on est en train de travailler
alors c'est le trans europe express
c'était l'ancêtre du tgv avec une
volonté de pouvoir passer justement d'un
pays européen à l'autre chaque hiver
près de cinq maquettes sont restaurés en
profondeur cette année c'était le cas du
château de breteuil ou encore du château
de chambord dernièrement ce qu'on a
repris sur cette maquette c'est les
parties supérieures il y avait des
éléments qu'il demeurait en bois et qui
commençait sérieusement à souffrir des
outrages du temps
donc on a refait toute la tour lanterne
avec ben justement son escalier en
colimaçon donc toutes les moulures et
c'est qu'il a fallu qu'il a fait le
reproduire et puis sur les quatre partie
supérieure du bâtiment les différentes
tours qui était encore en bois au total
2000 maquette composent le paysage de
france miniature